Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with how
every US senator is invited to the White
House today for a special briefing on
the North Korean threat Nancy good
morning good morning and that is an
unusual venue normally these briefings
take place here at the Capitol but
senators say they're very eager to learn
more about what they see as a grim and
escalating threat obviously an
assessment of what could be the greatest
threat that we've faced since the Cuban
Missile Crisis I think it's very helpful
to hear from the president United States
the nation's top military and diplomatic
officials will update senators at the
White House this afternoon President
Trump himself plans to drop by after
issuing this blunt assessment during a
meeting with ambassador nikki Haley on
Monday this is a real prayer to the
world whether we want to talk about it
or not look there is a big world problem
senators typically meet with briefers in
a secure room in the basement of the US
Capitol not an unsecured auditorium at
the White House why do you think the
White House wants to do it there I don't
know
but since it's the first time the
president's invited the entire Senate
over I think we should go and hear what
he has to say South Carolina Republican
Lindsey Graham argued the White House
setting sends an important message I
think going to the commander-in-chief's
house it's the right place for Congress
to be you know the world's watching
we're going to his house and listen to
his concerns senators Graham and McCain
had dinner with the president earlier
this week they say it doesn't appear
he's made up his mind yet about whether
to use force those same military brief
roles were be coming here to the capital
later today Charlie to fill in all 435
members of the House of Representatives
as well thanks Nancy